- Good afternoon everyone.
Today we are gonna talk about
innovations in data analytics,
and my name is Kinshuk Pahare.
I'm head of product for
our analytics portfolio.
That's Glue, EMR, Athena, and Redshift.
With me is Neil Mukerje and Anjali
who is engineering manager at Netflix.
And today the topic is
gonna be around innovation
in data processing.
So let's dive right in.
This is gonna be our agenda.
We are gonna just talk
about latest innovations,
specifically touch on
some of the agentic
innovations we have done.
We are gonna talk about Iceberg
and ease of use, innovations
that we have done.
And finally, Anjali is gonna share
how Netflix is leveraging EMR
for their data processing workloads.
So within data processing services,
you're familiar with Glue ETL,
which is used for
serverless data integration.
You're obviously familiar with EMR.
EMR is one of those services
which had been around since 2009.
It is used primarily for the purpose
of open source data processing.
Customers use EMR and multiple
engines that EMR supports
for their data workloads.
And Athena, which is our
interactive query service
that is primarily used for
querying your data lake in S3.
Together, you know, customers
are using these services
to author their, you know, data pipelines,
querying their data for
interactive workload on,
you know, 300 million plus
Redshift Serverless queries
are executed per week.
There's a 19 years of
innovation that goes behind it.
There are a billion plus Athena queries
that are executed against
the data lake every week.
And then EMR Serverless, one
of the fastest growing service,
executes about 300 million Spark jobs.
Together, these services query
about a hundred petabyte plus
of data from S3 during
the course of the week.
And these data workloads
are primarily built
on S3 as the data lake.
So over years, S3 has
emerged as the best place
to build your data lake.
There are exabytes of,
you know, Parquet data
that is stored in S3 for the purpose
of data lake and querying.
Now Parquet, as you're
familiar, is a columnar format
that is typically used
for building data lakes
because it is much more
efficient for reads and writes.
And the engines that are writing
and reading from S3 are, you know,
behind Glue EMR and Athena.
There are 25 million
plus requests per second
against those data lakes.
So the reason I'm sharing
this, these numbers,
these are exciting numbers.
It's actually a testament of
how customers are trusting
these data processing services
and our S3 for building their, you know,
mission critical data applications.
Now, every year we
gather here to talk about
how we are gonna make it even better.
This is, you know, my fourth
re:Invent, but, you know,
the Athena service was
launched nine years ago
in one of these re:Invent.
Glue was launched in 2017, August.
So these are all the
services where, you know,
they have years of
innovation behind these,
exactly for the purpose of data processing
and querying these data.
So, the first and foremost,
price performance is key for us.
This is a recurring theme year after year.
This year also,
our engineering has delivered
the AWS Spark performance,
which exceed open source
Spark performance by 4.5x.
It's 2x better for writes
and about 5.4x better
if you use a Spark 4.0
which is the new innovation
that we have done.
The reason why performance
becomes important
is that faster the Spark engine,
better you're able to
meet your SLA targets
and together you're also able
to actually realize pricing
and the cost gains.
Because if a compute
or if a data processing
job finishes faster,
you're actually paying
lower price for that.
So with the price
performance out of the way,
there are four innovation themes this year
that the team is driving.
Iceberg has emerged as the
standard for building data lakes.
The key advantage is that
you can build a data lake
in Iceberg and use any engine
to query that data lake.
AI agents in the context of
data processing have emerged
and they're solving some
of the most gnarly problems
of data engineering.
And I'm gonna talk about
some of these in my session.
And then Neil is gonna talk about
how we are using data agent
for some of the ease of use, use cases.
And finally, governance.
Governance is always a topic of interest
for a lot of our customers.
How do you govern data lake?
How do you actually ensure
fine grained access control?
How do you ensure that the identity
of an end user is carried forward
for all your enforcement decision
when it comes to querying
and writing data lakes?
So with that out of the way,
let's start with the AI agents in data.
Now, AI agents have many applications.
This had been a year of AI
agent in various contexts.
So, for this talk, we are gonna focus
on one of the hardest problem
that data engineers face
which is upgrading a Spark runtime
from version X.Y to version P.Q.
Now, the Spark version upgrade
always had been a challenge.
The reason it is getting
exasperated is because of the fact
that all the data lake
innovations depend on the latest
and the greatest Spark runtime.
Now, obviously as a practitioner,
everyone should run the
latest Spark version
to get the best performance out of it,
get the best data lake
performance out of it,
as well as, you know,
the features out of it.
But it's not usually a
easier upgrade to achieve.
There are two problems that
compound the Spark upgrade.
Number one, there is a code upgrade part,
but then there is also
a data consistency part.
So it's not just about you
can upgrade the Spark code,
it compiles well, but is
it actually the same thing
with the data that your
previous version was doing?
So there are third elements.
And in practice what end up happening is
that the data engineers have to iterate
while they're upgrading the code.
So you upgrade the code,
see some new error messages,
edit the code, rinse and repeat.
That process end up becoming
not only the time consuming,
it is also not a foolproof process
because it end up happening
that you miss a transform,
which is defined differently
in the latest Spark version.
To solve this, we have
unleashed the AI agent
for Spark upgrade.
The way this agent works is similar to
how a data engineer works.
It actually builds a plan for the upgrade.
And to build the plan,
it actually reads through
your project structure
and it generates an upgrade plan.
It tells you that,
hey, this is what I'm planning to achieve.
You can look at the plan, edit the plan,
you can provide your own
upgrade plan depending on,
you know, how your pipeline is structured.
The next stage is to build and execute.
And this is the stage where
it will execute this plan,
see the error messages,
edit the code based on the
error message, rinse and repeat.
So it will do the same thing,
which a data engineer is expected to do,
but it will do it in an automatic fashion.
Finally, when the code is
upgraded and it's compiling well,
so all the test plans are passing,
it's also gonna do a data quality check.
And what I mean by data quality check?
It was, the AI agent will actually look
at your data structure
before and after upgrade,
whether the schema matches,
whether the column type matches,
whether the data, you know,
the size of the data matches.
It will do all those checks
and then it will say that,
okay, this is ready for your,
you know, this code is finally upgraded.
Throughout the process,
you are in full control.
There is a guardrail
which can be configured.
You can actually say
that I want to manually
execute every single step
in the plan, or I want
agent, I trust the agent
and I trust it to upgrade
the code properly.
And during all the runs and all the build
and all these, you know,
the entire process,
you have access to the observability logs.
So you can actually see
what changes it has done.
And I'm gonna show you a demo
which actually talks about how
this works in the practice.
It also, like, what I
didn't mention before,
you can actually upgrade
your entire pipeline
or multiple pipelines.
The task that used to take six months,
sometimes six to 12 months, in minutes.
Because this agent is actually, you know,
automatically able to
achieve some of these,
you know, very hard to find
problems, the Spark problems
and act upon it.
So in this case, here's a little demo,
help me upgrade from,
you know, 2.4 to 3.5.
It will say, okay, you
want me to upgrade this?
I read through the file,
I read through your project structure.
It will actually build a plan.
It will say, hey, do you like this plan?
When you say I like
this plan, you can say,
and it is gonna actually say,
here are the steps which
I'm about to execute.
And as part of the execution
you can save plan and proceed.
And finally it will say,
okay, I found this diff
between the previous
version and new version.
Here are all the changes
which I'm about to execute.
Do you approve?
It's gonna hit yes and then
it's gonna keep doing this
for every single process.
And finally it will tell you exactly
what changes it made, a diff doc.
And once you're satisfied
with this upgrade,
you can actually execute
this into product.
FINRA is using this upgrade
agent for the purpose of,
you know, upgrading their
multiple data pipelines.
The second innovation,
which I talked about
is support for Iceberg V3.
Iceberg V3 is the latest table format.
It is based out of Iceberg version 1.10.
It supports some of the new capabilities
around Deletion Vectors, Row-Lineage.
All of these are available to you
as part of EMR Spark runtime 7.12.
In case you're not aware,
EMR Spark runtime is
also shared with Glue ETL
as well as Athena.
These are all the Spark runtimes
which benefit from the same
innovations that are delivered
with the EMR 7.12.
So you get the same
performance characteristics,
you get the same feature
set as part of Iceberg V3.
And what Deletion Vectors
and Row-lineage allows you
to do is it actually makes it easier
for you to manage your data lake.
It reduces your right
amplification problems,
it eliminates smart delete problems
and, you know, it is, it
makes it very, very efficient
for you to actually build
and maintain your data.
We're also announcing
EMR Spark version 4.0.
It is supporting, you know,
the latest greatest Iceberg
version as just talked about.
It is also 5.4 times faster
than the open source Spark,
which means you are
able to use a Spark 4.0
and achieve your SLA
or reduce your cost of
operating a pipeline
by an equivalent amount.
Finally, there is another
launch that we did this year,
which is Iceberg Materialized View.
Materialized View, as
you're familiar with,
allows you to define a view in the SQL
and Iceberg Materialized
Views are Iceberg tables
that are result of that
SQL code execution.
So it automatically speeds up your,
you know, query from your Spark engine.
It is compatible with the Iceberg APIs,
which means when they are
executed as part of SQL queries,
they manifest as a catalog object.
And against that catalog object,
you can run your Athena, Spark or,
you know, EMR Spark or Glue ETL queries.
And more importantly,
you can actually do incremental refresh
to the Iceberg views.
So what that means is
that instead of having
to configure an ETL pipeline
and configure all the triggers
and all the scheduling,
you can just define a materialized view,
which is refreshed automatically based
on frequency that you choose
or based on, you know, as
soon as the data is available,
it automatically gets refreshed.
This is available as part
of the Glue data catalog.
The view definitions are
stored in the catalog.
They can be, you know, accessed from EMR,
Spark, Glue ETL Spark or Athena Spark.
And it is an announcement
we did yesterday.
So with that I'm gonna hand off to Neil
who's gonna talk about ease of use.
- Everyone, let's focus on features
that focus on ease of use, right?
So the most shiny feature
that we have is SageMaker notebooks.
Now it is important to note
that SageMaker Studio is the
new UI, the new front end
for all data processing as well as AI ML
which means whether you're
using EMR or Glue or Athena,
your main UI front end for
users is SageMaker Studio.
And SageMaker notebooks
is the newest addition
to SageMaker Studio.
It's a new modern notebook experience
that comes with a purpose-built AI agent.
You can get started in seconds.
And you can choose the language
best suited for your task,
which can be SQL, which
can be Python or Spark.
And what is great about it is
that you can start with Python
and you can seamlessly scale
to, you know, Spark workloads
to handle large data sets.
Now let's see how that works.
Behind the scene, SageMaker Notebook steps
into Athena for Apache Spark
to deliver the Spark capabilities.
Now, Athena for Apache Spark
uses the same performance
runtime engine as EMR.
It actually uses EMR
5.12, which is 4.7x faster
than open source Spark.
Being serverless, of course,
it eliminates all management overhead
and it starts up and scales
in a low order of seconds,
which means if you go into
notebook and type Spark,
within seconds, you have a
massive spark cluster ready
for you for data processing.
And what is unique about it is that,
the architecture allows a
unified authoring execution
and debugging experience across
Python and Spark workloads.
Now let's see how that works.
So SageMaker Notebook connects
to Athena Spark using Spark Connect.
So Spark Connect is a new
client server architecture
in Spark that separates
the client application
from the remote Spark driver
while establishing a protocol
to seamlessly exchange
data between the two,
facilitating remote execution which means
that really when you type
Spark on a notebook cell,
it appears that Spark is
running locally in the notebook
while it's actually running
on a massive cluster.
Behind the scene, you can
debug Spark variables just
as you can debug Python variables.
And which means that now
you can tap into Python
and SQL, maybe Python
packages like, you know,
pandas and duckDB etc. for
small to medium data sets
and you can tap into Spark
for large scale data
processing at the same time.
Now let's have a deeper
look at the AI agent that,
you know, comes with the notebook.
Now the AI agent experience is embedded
in the notebook interface, right?
It's on the right hand
side of your notebook.
It understands your data catalog.
It understands your business metadata.
It can generate SQL of the right dialect,
which is Spark SQL or Athena
SQL if you're using Athena.
It can generate Python code, Spark code,
which is PySpark code.
And it can also do more
than generate data.
It can actually generate an entire plan,
a full notebook filled up itself
to achieve a specific outcome.
So you can really talk to it.
So, let's have a quick demo
of how the data agent works.
So, in this example,
in my data agent panel,
I ask a question, show me
tables in my sample database.
Now it'll go and discover
the tables I have.
Now I have three tables here,
the churn table, the ltv table
and the New York taxi trips table.
Now I can type SQL to
actually query it myself
or I can go to the table cell
and I can visualize the data I have,
but what's even better, I
can just talk to it, say,
can you please help me
visualize data in my ltv table?
Right?
And so, it then generates
the corresponding Python code
to build visualizations
and gives me a
comprehensive visualizations
of the data in my ltv table.
So I hope you like the
convenience and the power of it
and you use it.
So moving on to a highly
asked for feature,
we have managed Airflow now
in an entirely serverless
deployment, right?
Of course Airflow is, you know,
extremely popular in the
data orchestration space.
And now we have it in the
serverless deployment model.
The UI for this again is
SageMaker Unified studio.
So you can author, create,
managed workflows in a single UI.
Now it comes with an
enhanced security model
where now per workflow you
can specify an IAM role,
which means each workflow can now
have a unique permission profile.
And of course, being serverless,
you only pay for what you use.
So let's do a comparison
of what we already have
within a provisioned airflow
and compare it with serverless.
With provisioned airflow, you
have a fixed infrastructure,
you size it first
and then, you can have
a micro size and so on.
And it's always on,
regardless of whether
workflows are running or not.
There are certain capacity limits based
on the size you chose,
and yes, you have to
manage the environment.
But on the serverless side,
there's of course no
infrastructure anymore.
It's pay per use.
It's unlimited capacity and
it's entirely service managed.
From the security perspective,
there are some, you know, key
changes in the provision mode.
Your entire Airflow environment
has a single security model, right?
So all the workflows
have the same, you know,
permission profiles.
If you wanna separate these workflows,
you have to launch separate environments,
which means the authorization is shared
and isolation is complex.
On the serverless side, you
have workflow level security.
So per workflow you can define, you know,
granular access control,
which means you can now have
the least privileged IAM roles
for each workflow,
which really simplifies,
you know, compliance.
Now all of this is embedded in the UI,
workflow UI in SageMaker Unified Studio.
You can easily drag and
drop these activities
to build a gag yourself
without any prior expertise on,
you know, Python or Airflow.
And then once you have built them,
you can submit these workflows,
you can monitor these jobs
and so on, all from a single UI.
Now what's also available
is a 1-click scheduler
for Visual ETL.
This allows you to easily
streamline your ETL flows
and, you know, queries
directly from the same UI
in SageMaker Unified studio.
And you can create, you can
modify, you can monitor these,
you know, schedules.
Behind the scene,
it's integrated with Amazon
EventBridge Scheduler
to make these schedules happen.
Now, customers have told us
that it's not easy to onboard
to SageMaker Unified studio
and that is because of
certain dependencies.
You have to configure IAM
Identity Center and so on.
We have listened and we
have made the onboarding
to SageMaker Unified
Studio, a one click step
from existing services like,
you know, Athena console,
from S3 Tables, from
Amazon Redshift console.
Now from those pages with a single click,
you can go into SageMaker Unified studio.
We will auto create
a default SageMaker
Unified Studio workspace.
The entire process takes a minute.
You don't have to configure
IAM Identity Center anymore.
It uses the IAM rules
you are already using
in those consoles
and you'll land in a much
sophisticated interface
which allows you to use notebook
capabilities, query editors
and so on, on those same data sets.
Alright, so let's move into
a very exciting feature.
This is an industry first
where EMR Serverless
with serverless storage,
entirely eliminates
local disc provisioning
for Spark workloads.
So with this you can achieve
up to 20% reduced costs
as per our benchmarks.
So here's how it works.
So Spark workers have local discs,
and these local discs have,
you know, shuffle in them.
When this disc run out of
capacity, your jobs fail.
If the disc are your
constraint, your jobs slow down.
And often what happens,
you have certain tasks
which are stragglers.
So some workers keep
running for a long time
and all workers have to be retained
when some workers are working
because the discs have
shuffled data in them.
This makes Spark scaling
inherently inefficient.
Now with serverless storage,
these problems are entirely eliminated.
Serverless storage offloads shuffle
to a high performance storage layer,
which means you never
run out of disk space,
you don't face any job failures,
your jobs never slow down.
And as the shuffle is outside the cluster,
Spark can be far more elastic,
scaling out and scaling in
as per the needs of a stage.
So the combination of
the compute efficiencies
that serverless storage brings along
with the fact that they don't have to,
you know, provision this anymore
is an absolute game changer in this space.
And you can save up to
20% as per all benchmarks
and maybe even more depending
on the shape of your workloads.
All right, so let's now move
to the topic of security
and you know, governance
and a very important topic
for enterprise and customers.
Of course the main, you know,
concern is data access control, right?
Customers want, you know,
consistent data access control
across the various
formats they want to use.
Of course Apache Iceberg
is very important,
but so is Delta Lake and Hudi.
And of course, traditional
formats like Parquet, CSV
and JSON, right?
For most use cases, coarse
grained access control
is what is needed where you want
to secure certain S3 locations,
you wanna secure certain tables,
ensure that the users get access to them.
And for some use cases,
you also need fine grained access control
where you have column, row and
cell level security as well.
So let's see how these,
we have made a lot of launches this year,
you know, focused on
security and governance.
So let's see how all of this,
you know, comes together.
So the first we'll focus
on is coarse grained access
for S3 locations.
Now, for this, the recommendation is
to use S3 Access Grants of course,
where you can have simple
SQL like permissions
where you can have read,
write, you know, permissions
to S3 buckets, prefixes
as well as objects.
So how it works is that when
you submit a job, your job,
the engine simply looks
up S3 Access Grants,
gets scoped down credentials
and uses those credentials
to talk to S3.
Now this has been in EMR for a while from,
you know, 6.15+. It is
now also in Glue with 5.0
and it works, you know, consistently
across all table formats.
Now let's look at coarse grained access
for actually tables in your catalog.
This is definitely the most
common, you know, scenario
where what you want is
you don't wanna deal
with in a fine grained
access control overhead,
but you want to grant users
access to certain tables, right?
So this is, this has
no performance overhead
because it's just filtering of metadata
and the expectation is,
of course, full support,
which means read, write, you know,
support for all the use cases.
It's a fairly easy implementation.
So let's look how, how this is achieved.
So the first step is
that the admin will go
to Lake formation and will
grant, you know, permissions
for, you know, specific users for,
you know, specific tables.
Now when a job is, you know, submitted,
then it talks to the Glue catalog,
which redirects to lake formation
and gets scoped down credentials back.
And those credentials
are used to access S3.
Now this is available in EMR from 7.9+
as well as is available
in the Glue from 5.0+
and it supports reads and
writes from Iceberg Delta
as well as Hudi tables.
Alright, so let's now look at
fine grained access control
where you want column, row as
well as cell level security,
of course enterprise, you know,
customers want, you know, audit
trails so that you can have,
you know, compliance reporting.
And of course this should work typically
within a granular R&D based,
you know, controls as well.
So let's see how this is implemented.
Here, the admin will set
a fine grained permissions
in lake formation for, you
know, specific tables, rows
and you know, column cell as needed.
Here at the engine level, you
have to enable lake formation
and now the user submits a job,
the engine communicates
with lake formation,
gets, you know, scope down credentials
and it accesses S3 as well as the right,
you know, catalog tables.
So note that from 7.7 onwards on EMR,
we support reads on all deployments.
Glue is supported 5.0 onwards.
I'm very excited to announce
that we support writes now as well, right?
So 7.12 which is almost
the most recent launch,
we support writes, you know,
consistently on all EMR
deployments as well as in Glue 5.1,
with, you know, Iceberg
Delta as well as Hudi.
Now this is a very unique
architecture we have here
where we separate the
system and the user drivers.
The system drivers is where
all of the filtering happens
and the user drivers where
your Spark code runs,
and this isolation is
what you know creates the,
you know, security model that ensures
that you cannot run a Spark code
to bypass the controls.
Okay, so let's move to
a very interesting topic
and a very important
topic for enterprise unit,
customers of, you know,
trusted identity propagation.
So the expectation of enterprise customers
is that the user will authenticate
against established identity providers
like Active Directory, Okta and so on.
And those identity has to be pushed down
to the various services, right?
And of course, the
expectation is end-to-end,
you know, tracing of all users actions.
So now this is possible
with IAM Identity Center.
So you will enable single sign
on with IAM Identity Center
which allows end-to-end, you
know, data access traceability,
you have fine grained permissions there
and you'll access based
on the user's identity.
Now we support this from
both interactive sessions
and jobs from SageMaker Unified studio
and on the specific EMR, you know,
versions mentioned, from your 7.11,
it is supported on all EMR deployments
and this works in Glue 5 as well.
So let's look at how this works.
So I have two users
here, you know, Charlie
and, you know, Elle.
Now Charlie wants to
access a specific S3 table
and Elle wants to access another S3 table.
So, when they log into SageMaker Studio,
they will authenticate
with IAM Identity Center,
which federates the identity
from Active Directory, Okta, etc.
And that identity and
authorization is then pushed down
to EMR when they submit a job
or start an interactive session
and that will talk to lake formation
and can give them access.
So I hope this was
useful of how, you know,
trust identity propagation
as well as fine grained access control,
delivers the enterprise,
you know, security.
Alright, so now I would like
to invite Anjali Norwood from
Netflix to share their story
of evaluating EMR.
- Thank you Neil.
I'm here to share our Netflix story
of POCing Spark EMR.
Stick around with me to find out
whether this has a happy ending.
Was this a drama?
Was this a story of
collaboration and teamwork
or was there fighting, action?
Stick around and you'll find out.
I'm Anjali. I lead the big
data analytics platform
at Netflix.
My team is responsible
for management of data
in our warehouse.
It's an S3 table maintenance,
Iceberg table format,
governance, security around that,
engines to access the data,
Spark being one of the big workhorses.
Other engines like Trino, Druid,
solutions around Snowflake,
new addition, LanceDB and
Orchestration Technologies.
This is something we have built in-house.
Netflix is first and foremost
an entertainment company,
but almost all the
decisions are data driven.
So when you log on to
your Netflix account,
TV, cell phone, you
start seeing these rows.
This is recommended content just for you.
That decision is very much data driven.
Which rows you see, in
what order you see them,
which cover art you see,
this is all personalized
and data driven decision.
These are user facing decisions.
And then there are decisions
we make internally,
like when we run Spark on EC2,
which instance type should we use?
Is R7 ready for adoption
or should we stay on
R5 for a little while?
All these decisions are
also made with data.
That is our streaming video on
demand, our legacy business.
But now we started offering
ads plans in some countries.
We started carrying live content.
Anybody watching NFL
on Christmas Day? I am.
Games, Netflix House, those
are consumer experiences.
And also we will start carrying podcasts.
This is all to say
all of these new business
initiatives result
in more and more data in our warehouse
and more and more of a need to
get insight out of that data.
This is a bit of our Spark story.
This started more than seven years ago.
Netflix decided to do storage
and compute decoupling.
That was a big bet we took.
It paid off.
Since then, we have been
operating Spark on Hadoop.
We cut a fork from open source
Spark, we hyper optimized it
and customized it for Netflix
scale for performance,
for a variety of use cases that emerge.
We operate multiple Hadoop clusters
and some stats are there just
to give you an idea of scale.
Compared to what Kinshuk shared,
this doesn't look like a lot,
but 11,000 unique workflows,
250,000 jobs, more than exabyte
size data in our warehouse.
That's some pretty good
scale that we operate at.
We have about 8,000, 8,500 or so R7 nodes.
What do we use Spark for?
It's a variety of things.
Getting insight out of data,
ETL, that's a very popular engine for ETL,
large scale analytics,
recommendations and more.
Then you would ask, if we
have this nice platform
and we have been operating
for all this time,
why would we even think of something else?
Turns out things are changing
a little bit for Netflix.
When we started out, our
warehouse was open by default.
There was no security.
Anybody could access any piece of data.
Netflix is a very transparent culture.
We still are a transparent culture,
but addition of new
businesses like ads mean
that some of the data is sensitive.
It has to be protected.
Our current platform that we
operate on, Hadoop and Yarn,
it's kind of hard to get
the level of security
and isolation that we need.
Adopting new technologies is
hard because of the scale,
the number of jobs and workflows we run.
A Scala migration can take a long time.
Python version change takes a long time.
Spark migration takes a long time.
It's a lot of work.
There is a lot of operational overhead
and cost to our teams.
We call that undifferentiated
heavy lifting.
As in, this work is important,
but it's not moving the
needle for business.
We would like to see how
we can offload this work,
reduce this work for our teams.
Limited support for specialized hardware,
with Gen AI use cases
emerging, we need GPU support,
which is again, harder to
do with our current setup.
Our environment is good,
but it's a little bit
difficult to use and debug.
Ease of use is not where
we would like it to be.
And this is where we started
thinking about Amazon EMR.
This journey started Q4
of 2024 where we said,
you know what, let's check out EMR.
And turns out it provides isolation,
it provides improved security,
it provides frequent releases
every 90 days, every quarter.
Along with that comes new
Iceberg, new Python, Scala,
all the nice support,
reduces operational overhead,
things scale up, auto scale,
up, down, supports GPUs,
integrates very well with the rest
of the AWS services like
S3, IAM and other things.
So what did we test?
EMR comes in various flavors.
We started with testing EMR on EC2.
Couple reasons. One is it is very close to
how we operate our current system.
While we want managed services,
we also want to kind get there slowly.
We still wanna be able to
tune the knobs, you know,
change the configs, make sure
things work for our users.
We tested feature compatibility.
This was important because as I mentioned,
we have customized our
Spark for Netflix users.
We tested performance.
We started with TPC-DS, checks out,
and then we decided to
bring in our user workflows.
These are representative user workflows.
We literally reached out and
said, give us the workflows
that represent your team the best.
And they fall in various categories.
We have SQL, we have
PySpark, we have Scala, Java.
Then we tested for scale.
We basically mimicked our
production runs on EMR
to see if EMR holds up.
How is the resource consumption like?
Second part of scale testing
was saturation testing.
Can we just, you know, overload
the system, use up memory,
throw all memory heavy, I/O
heavy, CPU heavy workloads
and see how it holds up.
And then we look for
operational complexity.
As platform providers, my team has to know
how to operate this platform
and this has to be easy for them.
And then cost, of course, is important.
So we check that as well.
Here are some numbers.
If you look at the P90 column,
you'll see that PySpark
by far saw the most gains
followed by SQL and Scala.
Again, I would like to remind you
that our platform is hyper optimized,
so seeing these kind of gains is amazing.
Here is another slide.
This talks about resource consumption.
Again, PySpark shines
with most vCore gains
at P90, followed by SQL and then Scala.
Know that the consumption of
vCPU is directly correlated
to cost.
So the more, the less resources you use,
that's a good thing.
It's a bit of an eyeful chart.
We have a pretty long doc
detailing our POC and evaluation.
It's kind of hard to talk through it all,
but some salient points
I wanna touch upon.
Future proofing.
We are looking to be on a platform
that would just work for us
and will grow with us
as our business grows
and we see AWS investing
heavily, have strong roadmap
and have continuous
innovation in this area.
This was important for us.
Security, I already mentioned,
security and isolation
is really great with EMR.
Cost structure, we found to be competitive
and as transparent.
User experience is good.
Notebook integrations are supported.
Our operational burden will go down.
This is a managed service.
Performance and scale.
This worked out. I shared
performance results.
Scale results were also equivalent
or better than our current platform.
This platform is pretty extensible
through bootstrap actions
and so on.
It's not going to be as
flexible as do it yourself,
but that is to be expected.
But taking that into account,
we still found this platform
to be pretty nimble.
Observability and debugging.
We did not try CloudWatch.
We are bringing our own observability,
but rest of the integrations
and the overall story looks good.
We have a little bit of work to do here,
but the story still looks good.
Going back to the slide that
was shown earlier by Kinshuk,
we checked out three of the four boxes
and find them to be really great.
Price, performance, ease of use, security.
AI acceleration is something
we haven't tried yet.
This is something we'll try next.
And this is how this story ends.
But maybe the new story begins, right?
So we have decided to move
Netflix Spark workflows gradually
to EMR.
The way we plan to do that is
in the first half of next
year, we have some work to do.
We are paying off tech debt,
building new control plane,
job routing infrastructure and so on.
In second half,
we'll be migrating our
own platform workflows,
dogfooding, checking things out.
We'll fine tune based on our learnings
and in 2027, we'll be
migrating user workflows.
We plan to test EMR serverless.
During the POC, we kind
of touched upon it,
saw early positive results,
but didn't have a time
to do a deep dive there.
AI acceleration, as I mentioned.
Adding cost attribution.
I want to thank the EMR account
team, Vedi, Manju, Karthik.
It was one team.
EMR product team, June, Geo,
of course Kinshuk, Neil.
It's been, it's like an
extension of Netflix team.
It never felt like they're outsiders.
We were working together,
was a great experience.
Big thank you to Netflix
Spark team, Anurag and team,
DSI, security, other BDAP teams.
It was a huge effort that
went on for three quarters.
At the end of Q2 this
year, we finished our POC
and then there were more follow ups
because we have custom
patches, we have customizations
that we needed to talk through
and all that is coming together.
I'm super excited for
our journey with AWS EMR.
The best is yet to come. Thank you.